[Music]
and as cantor freedom was raised in
turkey moved to the us as a teenager
then became an nba player
then he began openly criticizing the
chinese government he wore shoes that
said free tibet which china occupies and
he wore them on the court so normally
the nba encourages political messages
they even wrote blm on the court but
criticizing china is absolutely
unacceptable to the sleazeballs who run
the nba
this show has obtained exclusive
recordings proving what's going on
here's ron klemtner who's the general
counsel of the national basketball
players association listen
so i got off the phone with the general
counsel of the fda
and he wants to now have a conversation
about the his their concern right now is
not so much
what you are saying off the court
or what it is that you're saying on the
court when you step onto the court and
what he was saying of course was
critical of china
mark lazary a close friend of bill
clinton's now co-owns the milwaukee
bucks
largely explained in another recording
that china will not do business with the
nba if athletes criticize china in any
way and the nba makes billions of
dollars in china so marc lazary obeys
listen china's taking a very aggressive
stance
which is
hey you want to be about us
you're right
it's business so their view is look you
want to be in our country you want to do
things if you're going to complain about
it
you're not allowed so what happens for
the nba is the mba is in a box
it's business it's business yeah i'll
sell out our country
to our main global enemy that seeks to
displace us and control us it's just
business
beneath contempt then there's adam
silver the nba commissioner he
acknowledged that the free tibet shoes
don't break rules but they upset china
and once again that's bad for business
you're not breaking any rule in terms of
the shoes there's no rule i'm aware of
that you're violating i to me
you know i think it's also look at the
end of the day we're also a business
it's just business what wouldn't they do
sell drugs to children i mean like what
human trafficking it's just business no
problem anna's freedom has a problem
with all of this he joins us tonight
anderson's great to see you i appreciate
your coming back so they just say it out
loud like whatever makes them rich
including selling out to the chinese
government pretending china's not
occupying tibet no problem
first of all thank you for having me mr
carlson i mean crop the mba is finally
got exposed and this is the evidence of
how 100
american-made com company is run by the
chinese dictatorship and wake up america
this is the league that we have been
supporting and watching and enough is
enough and this is unacceptable they are
mad because finally someone from the
inside that i played 11 years in this
league i've finally exposed them and i'm
saying it again enough is enough stop
bowling down to dictatorships
that's right it and it's the only
american supporters invented at a ymca
in springfield massachusetts what about
what about all the woke sports writers
who were constantly on the lookout for
someone saying the wrong thing has any
have any of them taken your side in this
uh well i will just say this you know
when i started to talk about these
problems for the first time one of the
actually
players reached out to me and said
listen there's no one going to be
behind you especially the media because
they are run by the nba so do not have
any any hope by the sports and media
what you know i didn't you know what
this was the right thing to do and i
went out there and exposed it all so i'm
i'm glad i did it trust me
yeah where's bill simmons he's a deeply
good person so we just got this
statement from the nba about one of the
recordings and i and i i want to read it
to you quote adam silver made it clear
that we support players including mr
freedom expressing their views on
matters that are important to them end
quote how do you respond to that
disingenuous statement
well well the recording said uh
something different you know i'm just
it's just sad to see how these people
still can lie to american people how can
they bowing down to these dictatorships
they will care about social justice
until it affects their money and
business business you know mba pretends
to care about social justice in america
but when that affects their business
they're silent and if any player that
goes out there says anything about it
they're gonna do everything they can to
silence you look listen i'm 30 years old
and they're pushing me to retire of age
of 30 and i am not returned i'm gonna
fight till the the that i get come get
back to that league again and keep
exposing them and
that's why i just can't take this
anymore
we're rooting for you
and it's freedom great to see you
tonight thank you